Christmas is so close you can almost
taste it we're going to get to the news
but first let's have a little fun time
for the fastest
missing your holiday package just check
your neighbor's house during Peak
delivery season Daniel shows that the
number of packages can reach around 100
million per day and when the drivers
cannot find your house number they just
hope they're leaving the parcels at the
right place One driver explaining how he
deciphers a confusing drop-off saying
quote the middle house had a large a
monogram on the door and it matched the
last name of the package so I took my
best guess and left it there okay so in
a case like that Jimmy who's at fault
the driver or the person who doesn't
have their address clearly the driver
every time
I'll tell you why and don't feel bad
drivers we have a president who can't
even find the southern border but stick
with me I'm kidding that's the only
cheap shot of the show I love you
here's the problem now I'm speaking as
an ex-cab driver the problem with
today's drivers is no one drives
anywhere without looking at their phone
first they don't trust themselves to
decipher which house it is let me give
an example I get picked up on 34th and
6th yesterday said I'm going up to 58th
and sixth he typed it into his phone I'm
like dude the streets are numbered just
go up we're gonna be fine that's the
problem get your face out of your phone
look around at the world you can count
houses I promise okay Katie have you had
any problems with packages no but I have
a theory and this does not apply to all
delivery drivers because they work very
hard and there's a lot to do especially
when the weather is bad and people get
very upset and people order things last
minute which does not help with getting
them delivered on time but I was on a
walk with my dog the other day early in
the morning 7 A.M and I walked by an
Amazon van and it smelled like marijuana
I mean it was hot boxed so maybe maybe
not illegal they're just delivering them
because they're not exactly in their
right mind that's illegal very good
point
yeah go ahead will Jimmy's wrong oh I
take the side of the driver okay first
of all if I get into a cab or an Uber I
want them to put it into their Google
Maps or their ways it's not about
Direction Jimmy it's about traffic
you're wrong though I don't like when
they get in there and they wing it you
don't know if there's traffic up ahead
and that little device is going to tell
you whether or not you need to go around
something can I tell you something where
to go you know like I don't know let me
explain okay okay I was just rebutting
he took a shot no this isn't a
republican kind of moderation
judge is spoken yes
um I take the side of the driver because
if you've seen how people are getting
Fancy with the numbers on their houses
these days they're getting a little
aesthetic you can't see if they want to
blend into the house I feel bad for the
driver that drives up and goes I don't
know him I'm at 5311 53 15. I can't tell
and let me ask you this how bad would
you feel if you had two cell phones
coming from Verizon and they didn't wind
up at your house they wound up at your
neighbor's house and you went a week
without a smartphone like I did I feel
like I need to fix the numbers on the
front of my house but my numbers are
fine are you telling me Jenny phela is a
bad font user so now you're picking up
you're gonna fight here let's fix the
numbers Jessica Jessica have you ever
had any problems I did yesterday what
happened tell us
um that it somehow I always check the
ask for delivery uh signature because I
I have a doorman and he will do that and
then they can track it better this I
don't know if it had been overwritten or
I just missed it it said no signature
required I called downstairs and I said
really and it was a president personally
everything that's coming in right now is
a present for somebody and he said
let me call the guy next door
call the building next door lo and
behold it was at that building and he
said it happens all the time now is it
the biggest deal in the world no is it a
huge Injustice no but my numbers are
clear on the door of the building Jimmy
with the judge of that I'll show it I I
won't show the audience because then bad
things will happen to me but I will show
you no I don't think you're bad people I
just
[Applause]
okay so I got a package it wasn't two
weeks ago and I come home it's late I
open the box I pick it up and I said I
didn't order this in fact I wouldn't
wear this so I oh I put the package I
close it and I look at it it's for
someone who lives that saved the name of
my street is maple say I'm maple syrup
no Maple Circle and they're Maple Lane
so now the burden's on me because the
driver yeah made a mistake now I've got
to close it up repack it and then take
it to the person at Maple Lane I don't
think you have to close it this this is
like leave it out in the rain no I think
you bring it back but I don't think you
have to find the packing tape and do it
depending on what it is you feel like a
creep because you feel like you went
through that stuff
I delivered packages that if you got the
location wrong they hit you this time of
year is perfect for snuggling up with a
cup of hot cocoa to watch a classic
holiday movie everyone has a favorite
but a new survey declares 1983's a
Christmas story as the greatest festive
film of all time
[Music]
you'll shoot your eye out kid
Merry Christmas
how how
[Music]
Charlie Brown Christmas comes in at
number two and the third most popular
movie is It's a Wonderful Life all right
which one do you like the most
so
It's a Wonderful Life of those three but
I love Dr Seuss's the Grinch a lot and
the holiday which I know is like a light
the Cameron Diaz Kate wins live movie
where they swap houses and everything
works out for them okay okay of those
three of those three no that's not the
rules I know you're the judge yeah
I like a couple of the chick flicks Like
Love Actually and Family Stone I do
family but the number one is uh is Bad
Santa no it's uh it's Christmas vacation
without a doubt
yeah you agree no Die Hard is the best
Christmas
and it is a Christmas movie everybody I
also love home alone as a Christmas
movie and I do out of the three like
Charlie Brown But Die Hard is number one
don't argue I agree with you on both
counts go ahead Jimmy home alone if it
was made today the parents would get
arrested for child negligence yeah for
like leaving a child abandoned Christmas
story is the best I'm glad it came in
number one on the poll although we still
have to count the mail-in ballots um but
here's the thing okay the worst one is
Charlie Brown for the same reason it's
the best one I love that movie it's a
seminal movie for my youth and it has
the greatest soundtrack but it also has
the one worst song you know the song
that sounds like you're dying of carbon
monoxide poisoning in your garage
Christmas
[Music]
you're right all right up next everybody
looks forward to Sweet Treats over the
holidays you already know that I do but
does fruitcake deserve a place on the
dessert table fruitcake has become a
holiday punch line where the majority of
Americans disapproving of the dish but
how many of us have actually tried it
lucky for you I have some right here all
right wow looks so delicious I don't
like it how do you know you don't like
it I lived in London for six years and
they like only eat fruitcake is that
right yeah
nobody likes fruit cake nobody just
pretends are you trying it it's like
it's like Christmas caroling had anybody
walk on your door and actually Christmas
Carol this weighs 10 pounds you want to
know what it is first of all it's false
advertising it doesn't taste like fruit
it doesn't look like cake it looks like
it originated in a Wuhan lab it's like a
weapon you could hunt with and you're
going to want to hunt down whoever got
it for you it's terrible what are the
what is that great is that gummy bear
yeah you know they're um
out of all the things you could have
around Christmas time for dessert the
Endless Options fruitcake is at the
bottom of the list but the thing is I
guess fruitcake is part of the like the
legend I mean that started a long time
ago and it's kind of it's come down
through the didn't they find one the
reason Santa wanted to go to every house
in America so he didn't have to stay
home and eat Mrs Claus's fruitcake
that's how it started
I'm out of here I'm busy I think it's
like the the original power bar you know
like one bite and you're full
I think fruitcake is another reason why
America left the Brits well it's nice
because yeah 3K can't go bad because it
was never good all right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else